so thank you very much for the
invitation so today I will speak about
another candidate multilinear maps this
one is over the integers so it's
slightly different from the ones i
presented this one so first thing i
wanted to start with the timeline so
multilinear maps are really I've you
know and there is this curve which is
known which is called the I've cycle and
so you have the time and x-axis and the
visibility of the eye thing in the
y-axis so every I've cycle starts with a
technology trigger so for multi linear
maps we can say more or less than so we
had some papers before that only with
the theoretical idea but we add
candidate construction two years ago in
2013 so this is your crib in crypto so
sanjam Craig and shy presented their
construction and then some paper started
using it and we proposed just the few
months later a second candidate
construction that I will speak about
today ok so that was a technology
trigger and then the second phase of
every IP cycle is a pic of inflated
expectations and I will like replace
with a synonym here I oh
well okay I'm lucky exaggerating so the
thing is since we could build we have a
candidate construction from for I you
from multi-lane unless this really gave
a lot of you no interest in that
primitive so this is really something
that is worth working on and then ah
there's a big like thing here and that's
the disillusionment okay this is mainly
the attacks so I have a bunch of attacks
fair so it's actually started so from
the beginning we knew that there were
weak discrete log attack on the first
candidate scheme but then the the CLT
scheme got a completely broken and then
it one week later they were too
tentative fixes and the print and then
these fixes were broken again and the
attack was extended so we're really like
here we're really at the bottom here and
like one week later then there's a break
of graded decisional deviant man in G th
so ggh is also broken in a way so we
really like their enough that was kind
of you know depressing but what what
about today so today I am I I'm
expecting that we under the Fourth days
which is the slope of enlightenment so
shy talk this morning about the graph in
do scheme here that appeared to at TCC
is here and now I will focus on the new
multilinear maps or the integers so this
is a modification of the first I mean of
the second candidate construction that
essentially is modified deeply to resist
to all the attacks okay so let's jump
into it let's let's describe what is the
initial CLT scheme and I will actually
go over how we made it how we
constructed it in order to understand
what
it so that's the second convenience
construction and this is kind of nice
because it's also a compositor the map
so the idea is that you can encode
actually vectors I mean you're including
yes vectors and you can when you add
them and multiply the encoding zit add
and multiply every slot in the vector so
this is nice and it gives something
interesting to build I you for example
so we actually followed the ggh version
recipe so we did some levels using
multiplicative mask and we did your
testing by multiplication and using the
shortness so we'll come back to that and
as GTH 13 and as actually GG h 15 our
scheme is also based on oma morphic
encryption scheme but our scheme is
based on the aprox imene on the fhe
scheme based on the approximate recd
prom okay so this game it was actually
used in a lot of papers because of
because of the composite order maps and
also because we were it seemed at first
that the decisional linear problem and
the sub group membership assumption like
we're hard in this setting so it was a
really something interesting here okay
so Simon's mentioned it this morning so
the current melted in the maps they're
really I mean they're really similar in
a way to a morphic encryption you want
to compute a morphic lee over encrypted
data but the difference is at the end
what you want to do with the data okay
so too instead of you know encrypt
taking a value a4a Mirfak encryption you
encode it okay but that's more or less
the same and in both cases you want to
compute low degree polynomials in
several and coatings or several
ciphertext up to a certain degree but
then former multilinear maps what you
want at the end is you want to tell
if it's equal to a certain value or test
if it's equal to 0 X you can always go
back to zero at the last level I am only
at the last level and you want that if
you go beyond the last level you're like
you have too much randomness and you you
don't know what to do 40 mafucka
encryption this is different you want
you want to really strong semantic
security you can do the operation but at
the end it's indistinguishable like from
random so you don't know what is
encrypted so that so the difference is
essentially here how can we provide this
helper element at level K that is a
defective secret key that will allow
only to test if it's a zero if it's an N
by ok so let's start from a do morphic
encryption scheme over the integers so
it started with a van Dyck Gentry
olivion by cotton a tenant 2010 and then
it got you know modified in a series of
papers so the secret key is just a prime
P and part of the public key it's
actually public modulus here it's a it's
a multiple of the prime time is
something which is actually really
really really large I mean minions have
bit large but its heart a factor okay so
that's a public modulus and what is the
ciphertext so cipher test is just a mere
multiple of tea so it's a multiple of
tea so it's Q times P where Q is not
this large factor here plus your message
and plus your message is not G Plus so
plus G times a small noise okay so
actually this thing here gr + M is way
smaller than T that's the idea okay so
we can like rewrite that slightly
differently we can rewrite it as a CRT
what does it mean it mean that multiply
so we add gr + m which is this the small
value here and on the other like mod Q 0
this is actually a random value and this
random value is what enables has to
prove the security under the approximate
GCD assumption so to decrypt you're just
taking out key you get this value here
and you take it moji and you remove the
g times are ok so we can extend it
further and this is as in these papers
here so instead of having only one key
you can have multiple key p is so now
you have multiple pies in the secret key
your public key is few 0 times the
product of the pies and you have several
slots here and on each slot you have
your message so the the ice coefficient
of your message vector + GI which is a
message space for the high spot times
some small noise awry okay so is that
just a way to extend it and it's
actually interesting because as I said
the random here is actually way larger
than the key I so by batching it this
way you're actually saving space I mean
you're not it's not it's interesting to
batch it this way you're you're you can
batch several elements in a cipher text
which is more or less the same size as
before okay so what happened on each
slot so on the first slot and when you
do operation I mean it's only random
value so the random values will like add
or multiply so it will stay right but on
these slots here so these are small
values right so when you add to the this
is like mud one of the slots so when you
add to a small values like that the
value is slightly bigger it increased by
like 12 bits but when you do a
multiplication it's it's like a double
size so it's actually with
multiplication the noise graph is
exponential so you can do several
operations or multiplication
multiplication but then you're you're
stuck because you have a like kind of
big noise in your
in your cipher text or in your including
and then you're stuck you cannot do
another operation otherwise it will
overlap multi and you will add
randomness in the message and it will
lose correctness okay so then you're
limited to like a certain number of
operations this is why it's somewhat
morphic encryptions okay so so far so
good so let's apply the GTH recipe so
first thing we want to add sharp levels
so we want this notion of levels in the
multilinear maps so what they did in GG
ate and what we did to is add a
multiplicative mask so let's draw a
random value mod X 0 so all the the
encoding SARM at X 0 and then you encode
a vector em at level J by dividing your
cipher text by Z 2 Z che mat X 0 so this
is nice now because when you do editions
of encoding you can only add including
at the same level because you need to
have the same denominator here and it
will yield the and including up the sum
at the same level and when you multiply
and including at level J 1 and then
grading at level J to the exponent in
the Z will add so you will get an egg
inning at level j1 plus j2 okay so we
got this levels and that sounds
interesting second thing we want to test
40 ok so in G th they multiplied by
something and use the shortness of the
of the noise so let's let's look at what
we really want to do so we want to test
whether to encoding at the level K are
equal so it means equal here means that
the vector M and the vector l are equal
to the vector 0 M minus L is equal to 0
ok so what is an encoding of 0 actually
so if we look at before so this is the
cipher text and in h cipher text you
have a plus mi here so now all the mi
equal to 0 so it seems that if we want
to test 40 and use the shortness so we
have shortness in these slots here the
air I x GI are short and then we have to
cancel this Z thing here and we're quite
to know it by this randomness here so
yes that's what i was saying so the ad
of gghs 2 x n element which will cancel
this thing here and we'll use the fact
that this things here are small ok so
let's rewrite this thing here
differently so we can rewrite the CRT as
a sum so it's the sum of gir I times
something that is the coefficient that
will give the CRT so here the PI star is
the product of the PJ except for j is
equal to I so if you take it mod key so
if you take key to storm at t1 you get 0
right so if you take this some mod p 1
you get only the first term and the
first term is what is chi 1 or 1 divided
by Z 2 Z K matki one so this is exactly
they're like the CRT itself and then you
also add this Q this random thing times
the product of the PJ so if you take
this mod Q 0 then in this is random so
this is random so everything is random
that's how we get yeah the formula
before ok so that's just another way to
write it and we're quite annoyed by this
value here because it's a random value
so there's no really way to exploit the
fact that these terms are small because
this value is like really big really
really big and it scrambles everything
down so what we want is actually to work
not the product of the PJ we don't we
don't want this term here it's like
really annoying 20 tests so that's
actually actually what we did in the
paper we said ok let's say let's take X
0 to be the product of the PJ so it's
mean actually we don't have this random
slot anymore in our skin but this lot
was what was helping us to prove to
reduce the thing to approximate a CD
now we don't have a reduction to
approximately city anymore but it seems
that if I give you a CRT of many many
values small values were like consider
and to be in the order of 10,000 or
something like that and the primes we're
all like two thousand bits and I give
you the CRT of these small values it
seems hard to distinguish it from like
any uniform element okay so now if you
look at an encoding so x0 now is the
product of the PJ it's just a CRT of
small value divided by Z to the J so
this is a level thing and this is nearly
0 ciphertext except that we drop the
first slot so now what is your testing
procedure so we'll multiply by an
element pzt and so what we want is we
want to let's look at it here so we
don't have this term anymore we want to
cancel the divided by Z 2 Z K so we'll
have to multiplied by Z 2 Z K and we
want also we want this to be small in a
way and so we need to cancel this thing
here which is not small so it means we
actually have to multiply by the inverse
of this here and this is of the size x0
divided by TI and this is way smaller
than P I so it means that if this wasn't
here then it would be way smaller than X
0 so you could test you could test it so
that's what we do we are actually so
this is a PI star and ZK and we're also
multiplying by a really small element
hii which will add randomness for the
security and we also multiply by the
inverse of G I so why because now when
you take so this is your encoding of em
so on each slot its regi plus MI so when
you multiply it by this element here mod
X 0 Matt the product of the primes what
you get is on the H is staying here the
P I start saying here and then you
multiply this thing here by this thing
here so the ck is like canceling out
and you have AI + mi x GI minus 1 so
this is nice because when all the mir
equal to 0 then this is this disappear
so the our air I are small x hir small
and the PIR size H 0 divided by P I so
it's it's way smaller than X 0 so
everything is way smaller than exterior
so you get this equality over Z and it's
meant that the absolute value is way
smaller and then X 0 but when M is not
the zero vector then one of these mi x
GI minus 1 will be big because gi- one
will be big mud pie and then it means
that all this sum will be big and you
will have something that is big I
compared to X 0 so we actually have to
give several and several pcts in order
to prove the equivalence in the other
way but 13 yes
ok so that was more or less the skin and
what was the earnest assumption on this
game so the first one was the great
decisional diffie-hellman assumption
which is essentially i give you k plus 1
and coatings at level 1 and i want you
and an encoding at local k and i want
you to guess whether the encoding is a
random and coding or if it's a value and
cut the product of all the others so of
course that's exactly in a way the
multipartite key exchange protocol so
everyone broadcast so that's what she
says it's morning everyone what gets the
value so everyone broadcast an oncoming
of random value at level 1 and what is
their share secret it's actually the
product of all the encoding but their
own so it's something at level K and
they actually multiply by their own
secret including at level 0 so it does
not change the level so they get an
encoding of the product at level K and
an adversary does not have the including
at level 0 so it cannot produce an
including at level ok it can only
produce and i'm getting at level k plus
1 but it does not even make anything
because it's very snow level k plus 1 so
it's hard to distinguish I mean the
assumption is that it's hard to
distinguish but we don't have any likes
reduction to approximately city or
anything and sm too thick parameters so
we had a heuristic security analysis so
we consider the summit acts like
orthogonal let aesthetic attack on
encoding GCD attack on 0 testing attacks
and the inverse of the 0 testing matrix
edensor tips and a tacky brute forces of
the noise and stuff like that and every
one of this attack was giving a
constraint and then we had the scheme
with because ok so we also had the
decisional linear assumption and the
secure premiership assumption that were
proud to be hard in our skin but that's
actually not the case so some share
Hanley
USLA came with a bazooka and shoot us so
they wrote a really nice paper it's your
crypt this year and they described a
probabilistic polynomial time attack
against our scheme and the attack is
really so it means that if you have low
level including of zero then you can
recover the pis and the PR is worth the
secret value you know in the public
modulus and actually if you can recover
this then you can break everything now
okay so I have to describe what they did
in order to explain of it we we try to
protect ourself again this attack so in
one if you have to remember something
the thing is very exploiting the
linearity of the zero testing procedure
so actually what is your testing thing
so when you can compute this mod X 0 you
are actually computing an inner product
of two two secret vectors so it meant
that if you split the first including
and free values so this is a negative
zero at level k minus 2 so lovable
encoding of 0 0 target including and an
ell program coding at level 1 if you
take this then you get an inner product
of the air is coming from the including
of 0 here and this value are just the
values on this lot of this and coatings
here so you get a you know a four-part
I'd inner product so you can rewrite it
this way this is actually a row vector x
a diagonal matrix where each element of
the diagonal matrix is this bi times
this element here that comes from the
pzt times a column vector and when you
see it that way you're like ok let's run
it with different including zeros and
different including see in order to
extend it to matrices so if you do it n
times if you have enough including of 0
a low level including of 0 and NFL /
including then you can
construct a matrix which is a matrix R
times the diagonal matrix with these
elements which are really secret values
here times a matrix e okay so we did it
once so let's do it again that's
essentially the attack so let's take the
same including zero the same including
see but this time we'll apply it on a
different target so no I will get twice
the they make the matric as before so a
matrix R times a diagonal matrix so this
time the diagonal is different times a
matrix C so let's invert the second one
and with I probability it will be
invertible because we're actually taking
the overall the randomness that will be
in the including that will be invertible
and then when we see that of course we
want to multiply it and when we multiply
it the see here is cancelling out and
here you have two diagonal matrix so you
get like the product of the elements on
the diagonal and now it's like way
better because you get the matrix which
is equal to a matrix R times the
diagonal matrix with secret values x
them r minus 1 so what you want to do
obviously is to compute the eigenvalues
from here because the eigenvalue of the
matrix here is exactly all of this bi /
be pardoned hi okay so that's just what
I what I said so you compute the again
value and you can compute them oh yes
sir so you were actually before you are
doing the inversion of the queue right
so you add to two integer matrix so you
can invert them over Q and then you get
this and this is over Q here and you can
compute the eigenvalues and this will be
a rational members so you get the eigen
values and that's bi / b prime i but you
get like the ridges form of them but
what we you do have is if you take it
mean that essentially from this equation
you have VI time beep
i is equal to B prime a bit i prime I
times B di so it's meant that on the
I've slot here if you multiply beta I
prime here with this including here and
you remove beta I time this encoding
here you will get a zero on the I've
slot so it means that P i will divide
the element that you yet that you have
here and now you can just compute the
GCD so you compute the GCD of this value
here because P is dividing and dividing
this value with x 0 and x 0 the it's a
product of all the pj so you can recover
p I from it and with I probability over
everything you recover exactly p 9 so
you're so you're actually computing the
eigen value so it will give you a value
like a rational number and the rational
number is yes exactly that's animator
isn't in the rain so then you recover
the pie and if you have the pie then
everything's breaks down so even worse
so one week after this attack to fixes
were like proposed but their idea was
okay this low level including of zeros
are annoying so let's prevent anyone who
have low level including of 0 I want you
to too so it meant that at the top level
in order to zero test you will have to
do something differently you'll have to
do a sum you won't have this
multiplication structure anymore whether
we're using the zero testing is like a
black box not modifying zero testing
phase only modifying the form of the
input and the thing is you can actually
generalize this attack if it's a song
for example it doesn't it doesn't matter
you just need a bigger matrices some of
our remarks you don't actually need low
logon including um 0 what you need is
that when you multiply all these a
which is here times the target B which
is fixed time the see you get an
including a zero at the top level every
time so when you ver eyes eyes and the
sea you still get an opening of your so
you need orthogonal encodings in a win
over remark you don't actually need the
matrix B to be diagonal it can be
diagonal per block so now it means that
the eigenvalues might be in complex
numbers but you know you can compute the
characteristic polynomial and it will
cancel out mode one of the slots so
that's different ways to extend the
attacks so it sounds really bad but the
thing is it's very way to avert this
attack we really want to remove the
linearity from the zero testing one
thing is the including they look like DG
hv ciphertext they look like the
somewhat more Fink encryption scheme
ciphertext the only thing is we drop
this random element which was helping
for the reduction to approximate icity
but in a way their form should not be a
problem so what we did in the the new
CLT that will appear crypto is to modify
the zero testing procedure itself rather
than modifying the form of the encoding
so in a natural the ideas will nudge
your test mod X 0 anymore with zero
testament and new models a modulus which
is completely drawn independently and
the X 0 which was useful so actually we
cannot assume it to be public anymore
and it's even better because if it's not
public it's meant that it does not rely
on the unpacked ization anymore so
that's kind of nice and actually at the
end of the attack we are doing a G C D
with with X 0 so if we don't have x0
Zeman the attack can just be more
complicated in order to
anyway i'll come back to that so we do
the zero testing modern new modulus so
we do let essentially we we keep the
same thing mod x 0 all the way long but
only at the end at the top level in
order to zero tests we switch to a new
models and we do this your test mod
these new models here it's all matters
it's a product of although the primes
yes I'll come to that okay so what is
what was the idea behind it is that
actually very some hinny rent randomness
in the current encodings so this is the
form of the current including so mod X 0
but what it meant that it's actually
equal to a sum of this form here so I
just the UI here are just in a way to
write it down more I mean that's a
scaling factor for the CRT so that's the
sum of this element x UI plus an element
a times X 0 so mod X 0 you have this is
not here but if and you take this mod X
0 but if you look it over Z you have a
value a here and this value does not
depend linearly on the air I which is
which are here so this varies like this
inherent randomness in the end including
so we want to use this thing okay so
this is actually different from the
random q prime that we had before so
remember before we add like this obvious
lot and we had Q prime times of product
of the pjs but this is not the same here
because when all the mr r equal to 0 you
have only air I here and the air I is
small and the UI is of the same size as
as X 0 so it means that the size of a is
the same size as this term here so in
particular when you have a zero vector
the the value a here the random hey here
will be small so that's different from
before because before
that's something that was completely
random here in that was that was large
whether amy was the vector n was equal
to zero or not and now it depends also
on the and the vector M itself so if the
vector M is not 0 then a will be big and
if the vector M is zero then a will be
smoke so that's a different setting as
before so we want to exploit this thing
here so I can we do that so our idea is
to switch to a new model so we we pick a
random large prime which is larger than
X 0 and we want to generate a new zero
testing parameters so that an encoding
of M times the new zero testing
parameters mod this new modulus is way
smaller than the modulus if and only if
the vector M is equal to 0 so in
particular if you rewrite this down it
meant that this was including here if we
take this mod X 0 so it mean that when
all the MIR equal to 0 this will be
small here so it meant that we would
want the UI time alpha Ceti to be small
and if all the MIR small this is small
too so we want this here to be small too
so we want to find a vector an integer
alpha Z T so that alpha is 80 times all
of the UI is small and alpha Ceti time
x0 is small compared to em so how can we
do that so I give you m n and I give you
the UI and the x0 and how do you find a
small integer so that all these values
are small so it's not obvious I mean it
amounts of finding a short vector in
this lattice here I mean the light is
spanned by the rows of this matrix so
what you could do is to use LLL I mean
you can use LLL you will get somewhat
short vector and we can actually
tolerate an exponential approximation
factor of SVP doesn't matter it just
mean that will increase our parameters
more
it's not really a problem but typically
you know we're working with a very large
n and in the ten of thousands or even
more it's actually it's a square in the
security perimeter so um it's it's using
LLL in practice I mean in in our paper
we try to do some implementation order
to show that it it it runs so this is
like this is pretty bad we can achieve I
mean we cannot run LLL with really
really large things here in dimension
10,000 like that so what we did is
actually very something that is going on
here that the UI are some structure okay
we're not here anymore anyway the you I
have some structure there a product of
pie and except one and then multiply by
something else so let's try to use this
structure in order to generate the alpha
Z T more efficiently so okay the UI is
here so it you know there's this thing
here and this thing is a product of the
PJ / TI so it's like it has a lot of
structure so the first thing to note is
that if you take you I and you divide it
by PJ mod and this is small why because
the PJ here divide this element p I star
so it mean that this is of the side x 0
/ p i square and this is of the size of
TI so it mean that is this all of this
is of size x0 divided by P I and this is
way smaller than n so the only thing
that is not a priori small is for i
equal to j so pj minus 1 x UJ is in
destin so this is of the half-size x0
and then if you multiply by something
inverse mod and this is like a full-size
so the idea is just ok let's apply ll n
dimension to this time I want to find a
small alpha J so that alpha J times this
value here Maude any small so I'm just
writing down the small matrix and
implying LLL this is way faster
so so for every day I want to do that
yes so I'm doing that end times so i
choose beast that LLL find a short
vector here on the first row so it's
alpha j time this thing VI chase vij is
alpha J times this element here and I
want alpha J to be more or less of the
size of square root of P and a bit IJ to
the other size and divided by square
root okay so i can find i can choose
beta that LLL will find a factor of this
of this size and then the new 0 testing
element it's just a linear combination
of this small of j so time is pj minus 1
and x some additional randomness here
that we add to make sure that all the
attacks are more difficult okay so why
does it work so i have this new 0
testing perimeter here let's keep in
mind that so n is bigger than X 0 so
it's it's roughly x0 and you have one
the size for one team or so x 0 x paid
the pj & alpha j is more or less square
root of pj and beta J is and divided by
square root of future so when we apply
this thing to an including of em what we
get is so this was the formula of before
so now the you I times alpha Z T so it's
you I times the sum so the I filament
will be you I times this thing here so
it will be a chai times beta I and this
will be small and times the rest of the
Sun so this is here this is the element
x h I data I and the rest of the sum for
to forge a different of I then you have
alpha J and you have this element here
times you I but this thing here you I
over PJ I said it was really small so it
mean that this thing is small and this
thing is small so everything here is
small so if mr
is equal to zero then you have something
small time something small so it will
remain small not n and you also have a
plus x0 times alpha ZT but actually with
an alpha that T define like that the x 0
x alpha Ceti is small too why because x
0 as f yes as pjs factor so when you
multiply X 0 time this then it could
cancel the pjs on it you know each
coefficient of the Sun so it will be a
summer small thing so it mean that this
is small too so when the MRI is are
equal to 0 then you will have a sum of
small things plus a small thing so
everything will be snow and when the mi
is not equal to 0 then this is big here
time something small but this will be
big and actually the a will be big too
so it plus something big time something
small but it's it mean that everything
will be big again so once again we can
prove that the zero test work and we
have to give several p ZT s okay one
important cabot is that we cannot work
directly mud x0 anymore so we wanted you
know in NN CLT 13 we're doing all the
additions and multiplications mod X 0 so
that the encoding does not increase in
size now we can do them over Z but I
mean the size is increasing a lot but ok
so why can't we use a very country
reveal magic x 0 anymore because you can
actually apply the previous attack mud V
zero which is x 0 x alpha Z T so f as it
is your zero testing parameters so it's
public and is your new models so it's
public too so you can compute V zero and
when you apply to a non going of zero
you get a sum which is over Z this is a
small element to this sum is actually
over Z you get this element obviously
and it means that you can take it mod v
0 and it will remove the a and we we
wanted to like use the
that they had some randomness so of
course if you if we reveal the X 0 then
you can cancel the a so it it's it's
it's completely useless so you can apply
the chain i'll attack mud v0 and you
don't want that so you cannot made x0
public so there's um there's a way to
solve the increasing size problem and
the idea is just at each step so after
each multiplication you will reduce your
including with a ladder of encoding of 0
so I give you a ladder of including
observer of increasing size so an
oncoming of 0 of size x 0 and off sighs
x01 bit more than X 0 and then to bit
more than X 0 and then free bit more
than X 0 etcetera up to x0 bit more than
X 0 so you have a large including of
decreasing size so you have
so this this was your this is the size
of X 0 so this was your first two and
today so you multiply them you get you
get along and coding there and then you
remove this one in order to decrease the
size help you up until you get something
which is of the same size as x0 so you
just like you know you remove them you
just look at the most significant bit
and you remove it until you have a small
impeding and sits in its an including of
zero you're not adding anything to the
value so you're not changing the value
that isn't good so this was described in
the GH v10 okay so now we solve the
thing so after each operation we reduce
the size and then we get a small
including again yes so if I only care
about asymptotics then I don't really
care about the size right so the isn't
about the problems that a is no over
small yes yes yes yes that's just yeah
so exactly then you will have a big a
and then it won't go in this in
everything will remain some polynomial
size and sure we could still do
everything so I think that bothers us
more it sits at the a is now innocent no
longer small yes
that's it it's X polynomial in the
number of monkey okay so let's just try
to run a shame well I'll attack so the
first thing is you want to compute this
including here as before but now you
have to reduce its size first so you
have to do this like to add a subset sum
of this thing here in order to reduce
the size so then when you like write it
over see you so you have a small a here
and you have this element as before but
now you have this sum here it sums with
something that is coming from this
ladder of anger innings here so these
things here when you try to apply the
pzt and then write it as matrices you
will get the matrices as before but plus
some other matrices here and minus
another matrices time x 0 so you're
actually adding a lot of things so when
you invert it's not really meaningful
anymore so it really comes up in a way
of saying I al attack and we didn't see
how to extend their attack in order to
deal with that case so we really want
you to use the randomness here but
actually because of our construction we
also have this randomness here that is
adding more thing and it that makes the
0 the attack in work even yes okay so
just to quickly finish there's a
proof-of-concept implementation so in
the papers I try to give a small
implementation each time for 46 level
and ate a bit of security the encoding
czar 66 million bits long the public
parameters is nearly fitting on a DVD
and so it takes more than one hour to
generate the public parameters but then
when you do the multi budget key
exchange
if you have to work a couple of seconds
before broadcasting your value and when
you have to unloaded all the values of
the other guys you have to multiply them
and applies as you're testing and it
takes like 20 seconds or so this is on
the on this computer or something like
that so just one small thing it does not
scale so bad with the number of levels
what scales bad is a setup phase the
setup phase is really increasing a lot
if you take more levels but these values
here it's increasing a little but not
that much
I mean and so this is as fast as a CLT
13 and in CLT 13 so in my in my TC so I
went up to 25 levels so I think we can
do you know up to 50 60 I mean it
depends on how long you want you to
spend in the setup phase and you need to
ask a lot of ram and stuff like that but
if you if ya you it's it's a small
number of levels but it's between 0 and
100 i think it's it's okay to say that
it's implementable in that ranch so in
the in the in the implementation of ggh
they went up to about 50 levels too so
this is kind of similar in a way okay
just to conclude so the CLT scheme has
some interesting features the composite
order thing and now with this fixed we
assume that the graded d film an
assumption decisional de feminin
assumption is hard but it seems that
also now the attack does not extend to
decision linear problem and so group
memberships and maybe varies like still
hope for a skin that are based on these
assumptions if you want to attack the
skin you have concrete targets in
practice we really the first set of
parameters before is 452 bits of
security so if you come up with a good
attack you're likely to be able to break
this parameter set and then this is mall
as the same efficiency as original Zod
and what are the open problems just for
CLT 15 because after we have a small
discussion phase the first thing is it
would be really good if someone can
further analyze and try to crypt analyze
this reparation so we really like
designed it so that the known at arc
does not seem to apply do not seem to
apply anymore so is it a good way to do
things can we improve the efficiency so
currently the efficiency is not so good
the parameters are really really big but
maybe there are some tricks that would
allow you to gain something and another
thing so we try to adapt the the
technique of before to ggh 13 so we
first put it in appendix of her paper
but then we realize that
there's a way to come around it so we
remove the appendix but maybe there is a
way to adapt a similar technique to GTH
version and that would be interesting
too okay so thank you and now is the
time for the discussion phase yes
high-level question that so the zero
testing procedure here that's the linear
modulo n its yes well I mean in what
linear in the are human in the so it's
linear in the encoding I guess so you
sum of two encoding to get the sum here
so something over here so not really
because this the procedure is just alpha
Z T times the encoding mod n right and
you check whether that's shorter not
that so yes so what we're where do you
see where is the difference between
would like the linearity that's been
used so okay the fact is in the in the
previous attack you could you could
write that down as a multiplication you
could have really a multiplication of
mattresses and now you have you have
this you have this sum here with this
matrix a here that also depends on this
value here previous layer in the our
eyes yeah it's just right in there in
this value here I know you also abyss
but this is not linear in RI I mean not
trial in there in this thing here so
it's it's really come apps I mean this
value to actually so it really commits
in the way it really mean that you can
write it as a product of three matrices
plus 1 matrix plus another matrix but
then you like your kind of stack because
you if you invert it then you have a
like you have a lot of cross products
and I don't know how to
adapt the attack so that you can like
ignore this cross product or use them in
a different way
so for the discussion phase I guess the
question is what is the state of the art
and multilinear maps what what do we
want to do where do we want to go so
there are some like four main things so
the attacks so we really need more
attacks in order to really understand
what all the art nessa sumption we can
make and can we'd like attacked the
reversion of the scheme or not I mean
really a lot of work is needed in the
attacks but then you can also work on
the assumption so there are two things
in the assumption is it what service um
shin can you make an existing skins and
can you based on Miltonia maps and like
more nice assumptions as that a liberal
jeans and you have a part which is
application so something that would be
interesting is to do something that is
different from efficient a lot of people
work on a building of Fisk a shin and a
lot of techniques are you know Killian
randomization and stuff like that can we
do something different and obfuscation I
mean really different and what can you
do with a small number of levels so I
said in practice you can implement for I
don't know up to 50 100 levels can you
do something interesting with that small
number of levels or do you need a lot of
levels to do a Fisk a shin I mean what
can you do with a small number of levels
and then you can have some tweaks in the
design to do you want a public including
space or not do you want to be able to
invert in coatings or not this is not
particularly easy but it could be useful
in certain applications so there is a
paper for example that does forward
secure key exchange and then they need
to for the security proven it to be in
virtual inverts encoding and that's not
possible in the skins winner okay so
that's the four main like domain time I
think
we have to work on and so currently so I
just said at the beginning we're
entering this I hope we're entering this
new phase so we have a really nice graph
induce thing we have this new reparation
what what can we do from now so that's a
discussion phase if anyone want to
discuss I won't discuss alone ask a
question that's okay just just wondering
so these these GIS right so I think in
the beginning in CLD you you know people
thought that maybe the GIS they can even
be public right yes then at some point
maybe it was not so good that they were
public so what what are the one of the
restrictions that you have on the GI is
going to be first of all like public
versus private you need to be big or can
they be small okay so then it to be so
at first we said they were privates
because because it was mimicking gt8 but
then we realized that it is we didn't
have any attack that really used the
fact that I mean if I publish them we
didn't have any attack except if you
have only one in value on one slot only
but I mean you can like go around that
so then it does not seem so bad to add
them and you can take them kind of small
so we took them exponential in the
security parameter but in a way you can
take them smaller you just want the
project at the end when you multiply all
the encoding is you want that with
overwhelming probability the product if
you all the values are random the
product is not zero so you can take the
since you have a lot of values a lot of
n then you can take them away smaller so
in the new scheme that's the same we I
don't see any way to exploit the GI or
not so exact I mean exactly the same
conclusion
that's also a question I guess blue so
like in guys talk there's sort of the
two moments right the private encoding
mode public encoding mode a lot of the
attacks apply only against the public
encoding it's right this far as far as
we know yeah well it should be 13 make
sure when you he been specifically keep
encoding the 0 0 then as an attacker you
have a lot of freedom freedom in
choosing how to get a top-level encoding
of zero you can multiply this by pretty
much anything you want or you can take
one of the others and multiply so you
get a lot of freedom and then you get
the freedom to set your system of
equation this bit by linear or trilinear
thing in many different ways and you
make matrices out of it etc if you don't
explicitly given coatings of 0 and you
the only way to make recordings of 0 is
so to go all the way to the top level
and then you know subtract a couple of
turns e the type of since the only one
attacks that we have go through you have
to get me an encoding of 0 the top level
single equation your hands are tied in
the sense of the type of equation that
you can make and they don't behave as
nicely that's sort of the place where
the current attacks distinguish been
public and the private settings okay so
like the question was given all of that
what is say the simplest application so
in the public encoding set against is
not exactly right but in
usually public encoding is used for
multi-party agreements like that whereas
private encoding you're talking about
obfuscation where you have you have
extremely large where you're very very
good very large levels again so I'm
wondering is there an application of
private encoding with low with
relatively low levels needed or
something much simpler to analyze or or
understand is there anything that comes
to mind the only thing I can think of
witness encryption but that still gives
a high level right now although it is
much simpler to construct an obfuscation
more than another the order really great
the new key exchange don't be relatives
there's public yes the graph based nhe
agree on the graph basting brush it
doesn't matter private according that's
the sort of one exceptional case that
where we have key exchange without
but but if you've still need public
encoding right in the graph based keep
switching out of documents say again yes
but not of zeros we always publish and
coatings of some things well yeah
occasionally you think zero its public
but then another edition about the
public encodings is that if you want to
use an assumption over muscle in your
maps to build something and you want it
to be a privacy type of production then
it's really hard to think of how you can
give a reduction without having
a part of things that are going to let
you log in but again 0 randomization so
that's where you actually need public
including to cool yourself or you get
like some sort of semantic security type
thing where you or chosen plaintext
attack we just like have a challenger
and you ask them for encoding and they
encode for you right it's not necessary
isn't necessarily you have to in order
to think of a good application without a
doubt none right because in general the
reduction is just a mental experiment
right in it and it should be just
getting something on correctly and then
it has to combine things gotten give it
to the adversary so you're saying
actually actually need to be able to
generate yourself which is having next
Oracle naturally because now reduction
expedia if the reduction in the process
encoding that was giving separators 12
copper and in order for that processing
to be meet you know meaningful enough at
least the way we normally think about it
things that probably need
get yourself 20 I mean not necessarily
but maybe there's some pseudo random
version of it right view some subset sum
and it's not enough there's not enough
density that should be able to get zero
that would be kind of weird
Super Kick shame just to understand the
state first write up the game change
based on ggh 13 is broken right down in
the sense of polynomial they're not in
the practitioner sense but polynomial
time and the CLT cookie still stands
life the thing that tried talking about
the morning still stands and then again
there is a funny way to get key exchange
going through obfuscation which also
still stands to the kind of birth but
maybe that's all right thing to do who
knows right so that's the state of
affairs right so having just looking at
ggh thudding there are two ways to get
key exchange one the straightforward way
which breaks the easy there so the
aesthetically simple way which breaks
and then there is obfuscated at wave
goes through office caitlin centner
zillow test in general you can office
give zero testometer reusing yeah thanks
ggh 13 office k20 tester using io based
on GTA 2 13 so it's not simply or
something about the result so the
approach is not sofas catering there is
a method to the madness
I mean so we have pairings currently can
we adapt any appearing application we
have to this new setting because here we
have you know random wave randomness we
have probabilistic and coatings and we
can extract some value at the end but
can we build everything that we build
based on pairings and how does it
compare to begin anything from doing
that can we use I don't know the
composite order thing which is different
from the composite groups in bearings
and stuff like that so I mean there's
something to look at and to compare here
so maybe I don't know any nothing that
was published that I know yes parents
still presumably viable and the best way
to go and these are not at all
I think we should see why is definitely
not with resin right now like to to
linear it's not clear at all you still
have landed three just coming from not
even the right yes sir ah feeling it's
not magic here that I mean you pair into
zq and all the value of something
special not nothing the sun i don't i
don't know if anybody who actually
weren't careful and try this i guess
they would be my answer you know what
choice try to look at applications that
only need two linear only need by linear
stuff and see what happens when you try
to implement it using these types of
maps whether you get efficiency
advantages oh I mean it seems like at
the very least things would be more
efficient I don't know if anybody will
try
so for CLT of Dean sorry oh wow sorry
okay so for the newest for the newest
iteration of the theme what is the
current sort of bottleneck attack like
the in the sense that for co 2 13 I over
there was a clear bottle neck attack
like I was where it was because of the
you know what I find one um so is there
such a is there like a current clear
bottom lock attack / 50 but in the
common sense in the sense that we're
currently optimizing the parameters of
the barnacles I mean you can't make the
bomb it as any smaller because because
of this yeah for example the number
price okay so the number of primes comes
from this orthogonal lettuce attack and
since we didn't modify the form of the
including between cod4 13 and silty 15
that's the same asymptotic thing so that
does know you can go around it so that's
actually that's actually the thing that
gave us the big number of primes and I
don't really see a way to really gained
a lot from that so yeah I think I think
this attack is the most severe one I
mean it has the most blue blow up in
parameters some attacks are really like
optimized as much as possible so that
like the the random
sorry the brute force attack on the
noise then we cannot reduce it much
fervor so right i mean its wisdom style
we have like a lower bound here so we're
really stuck for the other i don't
really know how to to like tweak the
parameters so we we have some I mean our
implementation is based on some
optimized violent and we really choose
the parameters so that it gives you 2 to
the 8 steps in the attack I mean we
really like taking all the attack that
exists they extrapolated how much time
they would take and then we selected
parameters according to that so that's
why if you come up with a new attack
then likely our parameters selection
will be not conservative enough and then
you might be able to attack but from
known attack I guess or scimitar or not
too bad
so again a question for the room pick
any particular candidates map is it even
is it known that say if you can break it
for dry linearity then you can break it
for higher level higher levels of
linearity I mean is there actually a
formal reduction of this type no
question anyone's considered
this is if you can think about like sort
of downgrading the zero test to like a
lower level right just just given
encoding of like 10 minutes minus three
levels right multiply that by zero test
it kind of looks to say you can I do it
and there's a trial in here did I think
the question will be what is a structure
that you're assuming for the attack with
only three for example I don't want to
so any structure know what is the
definition of a pepper and naturally
given the polymer coatings I can attack
right right right so given the public
parameters so given only the and well
liked it that would be one or given the
given I keep key agreement transcript or
something like this I mean I'm pretty
sure that's because they do more work
for exciting all at least the two gtha
and i'm pretty sure that i didn't think
about the ladder or if it comes in the
way the short of that you just take an
encoding at level k minus 3 and multiply
it into the server testometer pregnant
and she can't and use that with the
museum responder and the solutions are
not
what you need to do is destiny of the
status of music for MP does any other
cat that still be classed as equality
and now no I direct is your knowledge
cruiser sorry it's a good question I
don't know
so judges can you can you get good size
zero moment to the questions that i was
talking occasion it's you no matter but
why not I Dominican for dealing some
sauce of structural incoming they did x
laynie are the parent showing an exact
is in the various things going for
nothing about the actual it did have a
statistical to go test out all my works
at me give you a bunch of zero tests is
the mounts to doing it statistically in
the sense that data does not even exist
the bad encoding the part is the zero
test if if the parameter is regenerate
correctly which are part of the CRS but
not I don't know that about CLT 15 that
it extends but whether there are other
possible ways of getting music might be
like the chapter of limitations but not
much okay this larger so I'm just saying
that even from multi linear map just 2
i'm not sure i sent on the model when
it's on a referencing we can trust it no
no so it to multi linear map from
because of the 0 thing being needed you
will not be able to do it right but the
law you've got but using CPR
you do have if and only for the zero
test yes with overwhelming probability
no but there could exist bad in holdings
which are illegitimately generated for
which 20 tests might come out positive x
is wrong with this these do exist and a
bad guy can come up with in the proof it
so it's a question you can generate it
to the crs these are called a new the
CRS is assumed to be honest even with
the CRS with bad include English pasta
zero test even though the not include
use reason including bear all fine but
the prover has to generate some in
holdings as part of the pool those may
not be fine mr. Shaw answer that the
only way is the pasta like oh and that
we don't know how to hide their the
malicious and coalition device I don't
know if that can be handled in an
analogous way by just having bunch of
zero test and then taking a union
bouncing that I think so actually yes
but if it can be then it would directly
give it no no but there's still this
problem that you could have a nice and 0
but then just / something happen no but
if you do bunch of 0 destined that do
not exist no I'm saying start with a
perfectly nice final encoding of 0 that
it's going to pass this or is it
coating material yet but then the way in
which you constructed by multiplying
other things those are fake right
because I can always take something that
I code 0 / are where the car at random
and I am are and then put exerted by the
back great but then you in the u.s.
thing you checked multiple equations for
example right no no I agree I don't know
how to make an attack right on how to
make us an attack but it does mean that
there's something to be done right the
final okay I really need it but so there
are these issues I guess that's the
bottom line
are you saying she actually used the cdh
basic him I think that was the gosl as
the scheme right that from CBS that you
had with John and and there in the
hidden bit Molly constructor I think
that in that scheme that would not here
I have a question with the end so the
capital n yes so if you're willing to
use well forgetting about practical they
all together then is there hope for
getting it to be much smaller so the
question or the fo can you repeat the
question please can you take the end to
be way smaller than X 0 if you're
willing to do the LLL like the food
level I guess you can well I would need
to go through all the attacks again III
don't clearly remember the answer you're
going to take it too small and you
cannot take it too large I'm pretty sure
of that so if you take it too large then
you have orthogonal lettuce attack again
so you really like you have a small
wrench to take it but then I don't may
be very some way to have something
slightly better than what we add but I
mean that's not much different because
you go from an n which is of size n
times the size of the primes to n plus
one size of the Prime I mean that's the
N is really really big so it doesn't
matter so much in the end so i would say
it's it's not really an issue
small so you have to be bigger than that
for sure
I have a maybe a comment so going back
to the bone a Silverberg paper at that
time we showed that what we sort of had
a heuristic for why algebraic geometry
might not lead very naturally to
multi-layer maps but we was open as to
whether you could get something
elsewhere from elsewhere in mathematics
such as for example topology and I would
argue that that would be where one
should be looking as elsewhere in
mathematics to get multimedia message
and that may be a good topic for the
upcoming production of a magician there
so people want to go to bed fifth at it
between now and there and come out the
questions and club with what it is you
want because at the time of our paper we
thought you needed certain additional
assumptions like a yellow switch turns
out you don't know
photography and that was part of our
constraints of wine that would restrict
and once it was understood that you
didn't actually those deviations that
kind of opens up the possibilities for
where the epidemics you can find natural
so that may be a direction go in is
actually try to find something better
than all this someone else in that may
actually be out there so we had the
pairings that people use from the little
curves have been around a long time now
the petitions are familiar with them and
it just took people talking to each
other across fields to realize
and this would be a good case where that
should not be
with that we will break the lunch of
Frank Ocean after again